zahura begum fled to Bangladesh looking
for safety after facing military
Crackdown in Myanmar but this is what
she's dealing with now her makeshift
home at this refugee camp in Cox's
Bazaar went up in flames on Sunday
we have experienced a similar tragedy in
Burma now my home here is gone and I
lost everything we barely managed to get
out alive from this fire
people who live here say fire incidents
are becoming increasingly frequent in
the camp they belong to myanmar's
minority Muslim rohingya Community who
have faced years of persecution back
home there are many rohingya volunteers
who are now trained by the UN and other
Aid agencies to deal with such an
emergency
volunteers like me used Mini scooters
equipped with water tanks and tried to
douse the fire today we arranged food
and water for those who are displaced by
the fire incident I
many of the families who lost their
makeshift homes are now living under the
Open Sky
everything is destroyed we lost
everything we had
the commissioner in charge of the
refugee camp says the government will
help those who have been affected we had
taken some decision regarding the
rehabilitation of the people who lost
their shelters to at night actually no
one was under the Open Sky that was
ensured we provided food
dry food in initially later on this hot
meal according to a report by the
Bangladeshi Ministry of Defense there
have been more than 200 fires in the
refugee camps since January 2021. most
of them were accidents but at least 60
were caused by arson or sabotage the
fire has swung the spotlight back on the
struggles the traumas and tragedies
faced on daily basis by everyone here
despite all the odds many are trying to
rebuild their shelters in the same area
this fire is a reminder of the many
challenges facing the rohingya refugees
they're caught between the increasingly
dangerous situation in Bangladesh and a
new political reality of her Homeland
now led by the same military Hunter
responsible for the Crackdown that
forced them to flee in the first place
Bazaar Bangladesh